- Il voulait être la troisième
voie, il reste pour l'instant
en troisième position.
Mais avec déjà une satisfaction.
Qu'est-ce qui vous plaît
aujourd'hui dans cette campagne?
Qu'est-ce qui vous fait dire :
Rien que pour ça, ça aura valu
la peine?
BALARAMA HOLNESS, candidat
mairie MTL, Mouvement Montréal
- S'il y a des gens qui votent,
qui n'ont jamais voté. Je reçois
des appels, à tous les jours,
des gens qui disent qu'ils sont
motivés, inspirés par
la campagne. Ils n'ont jamais
voté dans une élection
municipale, et là du fait qu'on
s'est lancé avec Mouvement
Montréal, qu'il y a des gens qui
ont voté pour la première fois,
et ça pour moi, c'est inspirant.
Et je crois que je peux
réveiller la ville.
J'annonce ma candidature
pour être le maire de Montréal.
- Balarama Holness s'est lancé
au mois de mai. Il a choisi de
viser la mairie plutôt qu'un
poste peut-être plus accessible.
- C'était important de créer
un nouveau parti politique,
qui va amener un vent de
fraicheur à Montréal.
En ce moment nous avons
des candidats et candidates qui
ne se sont jamais lancés en
politique, qui ne se voient pas
représentés à l'hôtel de ville.
(cris et applaudissements)
- En 2017, il avait tenté sa
chance avec Projet Montréal,
pour prendre la mairie de
Montréal Nord, sans succès.
Mais c'est surtout comme
porte-voix des personnes
racisées qu'il s'est fait
connaître sur la scène
municipale en forçant la tenue
d'une consultation publique
sur le racisme systémique
à Montréal, après avoir réuni
plus de 20 000 signatures.
Mais d'autres le connaissent
d'abord comme un champion,
loin de l'arène politique.
- Ça, c'est ma passion.
(cris et applaudissements)
- Avant de devenir le joueur
de football vainqueur de
la coupe Grey avec les Alouettes
en 2010, il a vécu le décrochage
scolaire.
- Je ne me sentais pas
confortable à l'école.
Je ne me sentais pas représenté
dans le cursus. Les enseignants
voyaient moi et mes amis comme
des jeunes délinquants, qui
ne correspondent pas à la moule,
si on veut. Et donc, on était
marginalisés. Et j'ai coulé.
Et j'ai décidé en secondaire 4
que je n'allais pas retourner
à l'école et j'ai décroché.
Pour arriver à mes rêves
de football, j'ai dû rester à
l'école, et là des années plus
tard maintenant, non seulement
champion de la coupe Grey,
mais cinq diplômes incluant
un bac en droit civil et common
law à l'Université McGill.
- Balarama Holness ne veut pas
seulement devenir maire de
Montréal. Il veut aussi changer
son statut juridique. Qu'elle
devienne une cité-État,
une ville qui aurait presque
les pleins pouvoirs.
- 6 milliards de budget.
4 milliards, c'est les taxes et
2 milliards, c'est les services.
Et ce que nous disons, c'est que
plus d'autonomie, indépendance
en disant que nous devons avoir
le pouvoir de gérer nos taxes,
de recevoir plus de taxes et
plus de retombées économiques
du fait que nous sommes
le moteur économique du Québec.
Mais toujours dans un Québec
uni, absolument.
- Une proposition qui détonne,
tout comme celle de changer
le statut linguistique
de la ville.
Ce n'est pas contradictoire
d'avoir la métropole francophone
d'Amérique du Nord, qui
deviendrait bilingue?
- Un n'enlève pas l'autre.
On peut protéger et promouvoir
la langue française tout en
reconnaissant que Montréal a
une réalité multilinguistique,
multiculturelle. C'est
la réalité du terrain et
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
Montréalais et Montréalaises
qui sont d'accord avec
cette proposition-là.
- L'aspect cosmopolite ainsi que
le droit à des services en
anglais font déjà partie de
la Charte montréalaise
des droits et responsabilités.
Si le multiculturalisme est
aussi important pour lui,
c'est aussi parce qu'il coule
dans ses veines.
♪ Get up, stand up ♪
- En 1979, au Forum de Montréal,
mon père, un immigrant de
la Jamaïque rencontre ma mère,
une québécoise montréalaise,
francophone à ce concert-là.
Et toutes les différences
qu'ils avaient entre eux :
anglophone, francophone,
Blanc, Noir, rural, urbain...
se diluent, s'effacent et
ils tombent en amour.
♪ stand up for your rights ♪
- Bob Marley reste pour lui
l'incarnation du rebelle,
qui se bat pour une société
plus égalitaire.
- Et se lever pour nos droits,
c'est important.
- À ses yeux, l'injustice
sociale est surtout frappante
dans les quartiers du nord
et de l'est de Montréal.
La solution, pour lui, passe
par une réaffectation
du budget du SPVM.
- L'épicentre de la violence
est dans le nord-est de
la ville; l'épicentre de
la COVID-19 et la pauvreté
est dans le nord-est de
la ville. Et donc les sports,
loisirs, récréations...
on doit avoir une ville où
la santé urbaine est au coeur
de nos idées. Et la jeunesse
doit être au coeur de notre
projet de société. Et c'est
critique. Et en ce moment,
je crois qu'on est en train
de faire les mêmes erreurs du
passé, en continuant d'investir
encore dans la police sans
arrêt, un budget de maintenant
800 millions quand on réserve
3 millions pour des terrains
de basket.
- Dans l'hypothèse où
il ne deviendrait pas maire,
s'il y a une seule mesure qu'il
souhaite voir reprise par
la future administration, c'est
qu'une règlementation encore
plus contraignante pousse
les promoteurs à construire
des logements sociaux,
abordables et familiaux.
Sa course à l'hôtel de ville
n'a pas été de tout repos.
Il a reçu des menaces,
des messages de haine.
Son mariage de raison avec
le parti de Marc-Antoine
Desjardins s'est finalement
soldé par un échec au bout de
3 semaines.
Et il juge que l'écho
médiatique n'est pas à
la hauteur de ses attentes.
À une semaine du vote,
il se veut plus lucide
sur ses objectifs.
- Nous, on reconnaît
qu'en ce moment, on veut élire
de conseillers et conseillères
de ville et d'arrondissement,
mais pour vraiment amplifier
notre pouvoir à l'hôtel de
ville, ça va prendre du temps
et de l'argent.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, M